In the US, the Trump administration announced a new wave of sanctions on Iran...
...following this week's missile strikes by the Islamic Republic on US bases in Iraq.
In Iran, Tehran is denying allegations...
...that one of its missiles shot down a Ukrainian jetliner...
...and is urging the US and Canada to provide any information...
...about the crash that killed all 176 people on board.
In Pakistan, a powerful bomb ripped through a packed mosque during Friday evening prayers,...
...killing at least 15 worshipers and injuring around 20 others in Quetta,...
...the capital of Baluchistan province.
In Australia, around 20,000 people gathered in Sydney for a climate rally,...
...calling on the conservative government to tackle global warming and cut back on fossil fuels,...
...as deadly climate-fueled bushfires burned out of control.
Finally, the US navy says one of its ships...
...was "aggressively approached" by a Russian navy vessel in the North Arabian Sea.